parti tout ce que vous voudrez j'y
répondrai l outil veillera à merde
[Applaudissements]
hier j'ai regardé réfléchi vite là vous
dire la vérité je vous le dis
alimentaire je vous la dire suceurs de
garde à vue je vous dire toute la ville
qui gagnent leur gaspacho jure sur la
tête d'helmut à je dis la vérité attend
dans les conférences et j'explique ça ça
veut dire on ne sait pas de quoi on
parle attendez vraiment faire chier j'ai
pas payer donc c'est bon atépa pitre a
battu bordeaux barça vainqueur et
nouveau canal mans les cherry qui je
préfère entre camille combal et jean luc
lemoine
déjà je vous demandez vous ce que je
leur ai répondu moi je pense que vous
préférez camille alors à demain pour soi
préfère dans le besoin de moi je m'en
sors uc gens lui parce que c'est votre
ancien mais également jean luc jean luc
et jean luc un chouïa devant west
jean-luc sûre et certaine jean luc
warsmann 100% sur jean le cubain sur wii
et bookeen koné niang qui devait les
seigneurs de l'autre merci donc lieu que
je vais vous dire je
c'est chaud j'aime énormément calmy rey
je préfère dans lequel j'aime énormément
camille qu'est un garçon voilà que
j'aime vraiment mais vraiment dans je
l'aimais énormément au canada et
d'ailleurs pour ça que cet exemple parce
que ce n'est son voile a cédé 2,10 m et
jean-luc c'est un garçon que je connais
depuis 25 ans qui m'a beaucoup beaucoup
peiné quand j'étais vraiment dans la
galère
il m'a invité chez lui il m'offrait du
jus d'orange et du jus de papaye
non mais c'est vrai j'ai relu qui m'a
beaucoup peiné donc bien sûr jean luc
lemoine ces mois là c'est à voir
cholet mme norma camille
mais j'aime mieux arrêter rolala mais
voilà qu'hier je préfère jean-luc je
préfère jean-luc voilà j'ai oublié de le
dire mais j'ai eu et j'adore camus